if everyone can take their seat please
and if I can have the speakers or the
panelists join up here
professor Cooley when he ended the last
panel mentioned that we're now going
more into detail which is something
actually that I do like because the
other is visionary is strategic and what
does it do and I like that old German
phrase that has now become common in the
English language the devil is in the
detail ah this after it is still this
morning which you're going to stretch
into the afternoon before we go to lunch
we are four panelists who will look at
different aspects particularly of gas
all in the china's energy and gas is one
of the names of the game we have jameel
who is from the UK but originally from
Russia who has become a noted expert in
the Russian gas market as well as in the
entire energy space we have also a
scholar from China who's going to be
presenting the Chinese position and in
that particular order there we have two
more devil and detailed at Conway who
although he is now with the private
sector he also has a scholarly
background so he's hiding so to speak
and last we will end with someone a
little bit further north that there's a
school up there I don't know I've lost
contact of it and Cambridge from Harvard
who will also bring more devil in the
detail the reason it's important to do
devil in the detail is visions are nice
they make us feel good or they may make
us feel bad but the detail is tells us
how to get there if we can get there
it's the same thing that was said in
this morning's panel by Richard in one
respect Afghanistan is terribly rich in
natural resources there's one little
question that no one has really answered
or addressed how do we get to resources
out
very simple little question but the
answer is very is baffling the Chinese
is baffling everyone how do we get it
out that's the devil in the detail
question so let's hear it about gas
we'll start off with jamil as first and
in the order that i mentioned bend the
second and then add in den marina and
you can either stick there or join up
here as you wish and by the way i'm
going to i have a germanic background
that means i'm going to play policeman
to keep everyone honest and moving to
presentations forward thank you very
much for the opportunity to to back
columbia university this is now its
pipeline colloquium and which means that
pipelines is still very important
despite developments of in lng markets
and i will mention that a bit later in
my talk so what I'm going to talk today
I'll present the more or less a bigger
picture approach when it comes to
relationship between China and Russia
particularly how China developed the
strategy towards China towards Russia
Russia in some ways different place was
in Russia developed different strategies
to with China I will talk a bit about
row sniffin Gazprom and then how are the
markets are not changing that
relationship not only market but also
politics internal politics was in Russia
as well but those internet relations I'm
not going to talk about Crimea but one
thing i will just mentioned that
obviously is changing Russia's attitudes
and then i'll start with first
I think the biggest challenge for
Russia's relations with with China have
been the way they view their gas
strategists and their gas relations as
you know gas from from the very
beginning what's interested in becoming
a swing producer when they started
talking about developing their gas
strategy they were very interested in
building ties with China on the basis of
the same type of gas reserves resources
that were destined for European markets
and this gas gas resources are
predominantly located in west superior
so the idea of what gasps prom was to
build a pipeline from ulta region in
Russia to China which would enable them
to supply gas form from West Siberia the
Chinese were not basically happy with
the idea of being dependent on the same
type of resources as European consumers
they didn't want to undermine the
relationship with the European Union so
the Institute of using East European as
our East Siberian gas volumes
nevertheless the Chinese were and also
you know the issue for that was he
selling gas volumes are easy to deliver
to notice two regions of China unlike
the West Siberian gas volumes
nevertheless the Chinese were was still
considering an option of using those gas
volumes and to put those gas volumes
into a west-east pipeline was in China
which they were expanding however a
number of issues interfere one of those
issues was calculating the price of gas
because the Chinese wanted that to have
gas to be linked to you know link Motor
Co with Russians wanted to be based on
European prices and then all linked
prices and I'm Gazprom also was
concerned about being too deep too much
dependent on China and the one that
access to more markets within Asia at
the end of the day China opposite
insulation gasps having had the
relationship with guest room or that
negotiations be installed for for a long
period of time a gas from do you really
want to give any equity to Chinese
whereas Central Asian producers were
very very keen on giving equity which
means that the Chinese companies will
develop gas build infrastructure and and
bring up gas to their own domestic
market apart from that quite problematic
relationship between Gazprom and and and
China relationship between rosneft in
China have been somewhat different that
depends obviously on a number of issues
simply because one issue was that the
Chinese really needed volumes additional
security tional volumes of oil from
Russia because of the decline of tanking
I don't know how to pronounce it
correctly honking oilfield in China oil
price was not an issue since you know in
oil and gas market is very different and
oil is the real international market is
the national price and one interesting
thing is the Olfa deck they offered
loans to rosneft and roshni have needed
those loans first in order to take
control over the assets of lucas company
which belong to to to mikhail
khodorkovsky and his business partners
which was dismantled by the russian
authorities and then subsequently the
chinese provide provided a loan which
helped roseneath to limited exposure
financial exposure after they took over
to control over tnk-bp joint venture
which was jointly owned by three russian
billionaires AAR consortium and then the
BP this healthy chinese to rely on
negotiations position and political
standing within russian establishment to
in some ways put in the direct indirect
pressure on gas prom to reach an
agreement with the Chinese so Rosneft
really de facto became Globus of Chinese
interests within the Russian political
establishment and having having absorbed
loans provided by China rosneft
committed to supply oil volumes and
increase all works from 300,000 barrels
to 1 million barrels a day now this
coincided with this was a change in
energy markets and also within the
Russian establishment because in Russia
different companies provide two types of
services provided market service whether
responsible for a specific segment of
market was in Russia and for generating
rents for both society and also the
elites and also their political role as
stabilizers for the budget of the losses
a political role was in the system of
this elite relationships were different
elite groups were where the Kremlin
tries to balance different elite groups
and the basically corporate assets I
used to give power or reduce power
certain individuals as certain companies
within that system and what happened is
that the equalization really became
notable log based of taxed for tax
breaks of russian oil industry but also
he became a lobbyist for removing LNG
monopoly the monopoly that the gas from
had on LNG exports CH and really started
pushing for his civilian development of
oil but also making making sure that the
in some ways this is created more
precious on gas prom to start looking
moto versus library and gas and then
another another issue was the
development of ESP of buckland it's a
very Pacific Ocean pipeline as a new
benchmark potentially new benchmark
which were actually seeking to develop
in asia market
and this leaves us in today where we
have a new project power Siberia
pipeline which Gazprom is planning to
develop and apart from the issues of our
yard line there were some other issues
one ish is obviously the problems on the
European front both in terms of market
issues within Europe it's still a very
quite a depressed market and also
political issues the the European
European desire to diversify away from
Russian gas following the
russian-ukrainian gas wars and also you
know the recent developments talking
about after after the Crimean you know
Crimea Russia took over Crimea to
diversify away from Russian gas which
which somewhat creates more challenges
for gas form because gas from is now
more pushed to a towards the Asian
market has already been mentioned
earlier bye bye Alex and as a result
Russians are now more how can put the
conducive to building the relationship
with China and the fact that Rosneft is
now becoming a new gas clay which is
pushed putting additional pressure on
Gazprom and Rosneft is now seeking to
use the power of Siberia pipeline which
gets from his plan to develop to supply
its own gas volume so we'll see
potentially more battles between
different players was in Russia to
supply gas to Asia this is basically
completely changing the landscape both
was in Russian and an outside of Russia
to boost the role of China and Asian
markets and the Chinese basically now
have a dilemma whether whether they
should wait and see how lng markets will
develop or whether they should secure
pipeline gas and in some ways they
actually in a better bargaining position
and Russia because the pricing issue is
becoming is becoming less of an issue
for for for Russia Chinese negotiations
because of the pressure that's coming
North American no market the fact that
is completely changed in the whole of
the price structure already within
Europe the delinking of prices of gas
energy linking them from oil prices the
fact that is Henry harp is not becoming
talk about that later Henry copy could
becoming a new benchmark for for gas for
gas prices so 2020 there is a talk about
potential energy glad because of you
know we had seven Australian LNG
projects coming on stream of the 2018 we
have North American LNG projects and you
know that the Department of Energy have
approved things already approved about
the film 55 project so far to export LNG
from the United States and it's a game
chain and also with an addition of East
African LNG the question of how that LNG
glad where they put the create first
question is whether they will bill and
the LNG glad or not and the second
question is who will absorb that
additional supplies of ng and Howell
angie is changing the strategy of China
toes gas gas supplies by pipeline from
Russia at the moment of course Asian
markets are the most attractive market
for gas producers they're fighting to
get access to that market simply because
US market is not self-sufficient is no
longer considered an attractive market
for obviously for for for outside
producers European markets as I
mentioned is the depressed market is
still important for Russia because of
revenues and because of traditional
links I mentioned already that North
America is changing price pricing issues
in Asia ng Asia Pacific and some people
say yeah well if we have this additional
LNG volumes perhaps it's it's you know
they can they can be dumped in Europe it
is true but Asian mark is more
interesting because of the price
difference with European markets where
you
you make a premium on three to four
doors they're mbtu and in other issues
which which of the markets will absorb
the whole energy world because we have a
free trade agreement within that between
United States Japan and South Korea
obviously they don't need they don't
require any additional permissions to to
absorb those LNG volumes coming
particularly from the United States and
China with the subsidized Brad prices
with more regulated markets however if
the other problem is mature or a CD
market Japan and South Korea they are
quite from an economic point of view
they're not as attractive they're not as
growing us as a fast growing Chinese
economy and this obviously will affect
the way this lng volumes will be
absorbed by different markets and at the
moment if you look at the Chinese gas
market the way it will develop between
twenty twelve and twenty thirty you'll
see that the market ish at the moment is
negative because the Chinese secured gas
from central age they have guests for
myanmar they have gas LNG gas contracts
already which actually could increase
the in terms of how much lng volumes
China will receive but market niche is
this negative around twenty twenty would
become positive and we'll have about
sixty BCM of gas available the niche
available for on a Chinese market and
the question is who is going to take
over that niche is it going to be LNG
volumes or there's going to be pipeline
get from Russia and he again is if I
mentioned early the pricing issue is not
an issue anymore because Henry Harper's
a benchmark is changing the attitudes of
players in the Asia and is changing and
it's also changing the attitudes of
Gazprom towards some pricing issues with
China gasps from already signed a
memorandum of understanding with the
Chinese supplier 38b same of gas per
annum for 30 years a potential that
could increase to 60 DCM of gas one
interesting thing is that Chinese also
offered to join the transport the market
that
Russian gas on Asian markets which is
you know the new brand new development
if you compare to the Chinese strategies
you know previously during the
discussion of gas supplies by all type
line and here Chinese students really in
a much better bargaining position in
Russia because all the supply of LNG if
there is also plan on ugh Anna can
absorb gas gas volumes if there is lack
of LNG volumes it comes to plate it can
absorb those those additional gas
volumes by a power of Siberia pipeline
so for us obviously the challenge is but
it can become where they can get access
to additional Asian markets apart from
China and what it can it can become a
swing producer as guests from always
wanted you know so that it gets super
potion post European markets and to
Asian markets and one important thing is
that LNG logistics are better for China
for for coastal areas in China and
Russian realizes so it's a it's a it's
quite a tough tough competition so and I
think that the coming May summit we may
see some some interesting developments
because like i said the external
situation have changed the domestic
russian domestic situation have changed
with gas from becoming under pressure
from increased pressure from other
powerful players including Igor Sechin
the president of rosneft and also other
companies associated with boutonniere
villainous such as novitec and I will
end here if you have any additional
questions I'll be happy to answer this
some of these issues are further
discussed in a special issue on China
which Occidental forum with journal
published by oxygen for energy studies
which will be available online i think
by the end of this month and then they
will be working paper coming out end of
April May next this year talking about
when markets with politics consolidation
and confidence in Russia oil and gas
sector which looks at how different
forces in
Russian oil and gas universe changing
Russian strategy both of us Europe and
towards Asia thank you good good morning
everyone I'm not being a smart player to
make this presentation here maps
rotation will beat the energy club and
an incorporation of some high
corporation organizations this is a
corporation work return Lee family and
me as someone you already know leaf as a
research fellow at Shanghai academic
after her science we are working on the
Shanghai corporations organizations
energy cooperation my partition will
beat the quick summary of this from the
September to on the September 23rd 2011
energy ministers of China curvature
Buddhist type Russia and atticus 10
approved the CIA initiative with the aim
of strengthening the establishment of
the energy club of the sto by inked by
interaction with some former switch uni
countries on the last year's Shanghai
Cooperation Organization summit
president ctp mentioned mentioned the
energy club again this initiative the
new club should should brood broader
communication about energy strategies
policies and the security issues are
promote technology cooperation and cut
which expertise among member countries
the club was proposed by then President
of Russia Russia Putin during the summit
held in 2006 a project of the project to
strengthen communication synergy and no
hope the club was designed to quote an
eternity development and the
transportation or more countries in
Central Asia and to integrate the main
consumer countries such as China in
and Pakistan after five after years of
exploration and the promotion the
framework of the club was the present
pros presented as the sea and initiative
the CIA initiative identified the
consensus among member countries which
are expected to take on the Shanghai
spirit of mutual trust me to benefit a
polity coordination respect for multiple
cultures and search for a mutual
development to develop energy
corporation the club shall strive to
expend communication development
technology cooperation and cultivate
expertise among member countries the
club will establish an open forum for
governments scientific institutions and
business groups as senior excuse you
working group is being planned the
attitude to obtain it was the
establishment of the club depends on its
network depends on his national interest
generally speaking the club may have
strategic interests and also bring
challenges to China Chinese energy
security can be ensured and as new
energy concept can be realized
consistent highest bid groups drives all
your consumption which is expected to
rise 300 million tons of imported
material by 2020 the caspian sea areas
could have a strategy crow for china
given the greater energy cooperation
with the central asia the rich oil from
the chemistry can play a significant
significant role in the industrial
development and diversification of
supply in china the carbon oil and gas
supply of china depends on the central
asia depend on Middle East which is a
particular and stable supply from
Central Asia
and the cast busy may be more stable and
secure can offer more potential the
development of the western region and
West Easton neutral gastrous
transmission can be achieved can be
achieved Central Asia is an emerging
energy center and China can take
advantage of this to satisfy industrial
needs innocent young and address the
future energy strategy reserve thus the
oil gas transmission and pipeline of
sindh young can be assured
infrastructure such as real bees hybrids
and optical fiber can be developed the
cities and the local way of life can be
revert alized the pipeline from Central
Asia can be designed as a channel for
West is the oil transmission which we
achieve the coastal developments in the
western region and improved local
infrastructure bettina the continuity of
Central Asia from Russia can be balanced
Russia and middle it under meat and the
Central Asian produce pay close
attention to the Asian market again with
China stands as the stable and
beneficial energy market as member
countries in the club the producers
should consider the energy demands of
the consumer countries and provide
favors of the priorities the
establishment of the club of the club
consistent opportunities for Chinese
companies to participate in the
development of oil and gas in Central
Asia so the conflict with Russia on
energy twice and consolidate a
coordinating the energy group only when
the pricing system among member
countries is confirmed china and russia
launched extensive and effective
cooperation the standpoint of member
countries can be co-ordinated and
international details can be in host a
network that uniquely bring
producer and consumer countries the ants
the Shanghai Cooperation Organization
and the club contains consumers and
producers both which is very different
from IEA and epic countries with
different duties can incorporate and the
search for mutual benefits in the
International entry area which can
further change the global energy map and
push the formation of international and
the orders china is a strategy a buyer
whose orders are pursued not only by the
US but also by Canada these details can
give China a big see in the energy club
contrary to the conception of is as a
passive clear though through through
pleading and an amendment the relations
between China Russia and Central Asia
can be strengthened through rulemaking
in the club internal conflicts can be
avoided and the opportunities to
participate see any corporation can be
assured in 2003 their first teachers the
first transnational pipeline from China
to hesitate to kiss our customers built
in 2005 the Central Asia pipeline and
west east transmission pipeline or began
construction in order to bring guests
from situation to Shanghai Yangtze
cuando and many other provinces by 2015
pipelines in turkmenistan and uzbekistan
by US bank will send our 40 palin and
tay billion cubic meters respectively to
china which we all push the adjustment
of energy structure and a mutual
development the participating the
participation instant to Asia Chinese
companies can promote their global
images and took our international
responsibilities Petra Chinese Beijing
hotel has become a lead market in
capital of Kazakhstan the SEO Andrew
Club is a brand-new Capri
mechanism because it consists of
countries of different types and
interests it can be very difficult to
define and confirm the rules
nevertheless China should pay attention
to roll making altitude a bring each
line a bring it in line with China's
national interests and values and China
bond to do this these are the some
reserve of our creation work but there
are still some questions with we should
be careful when we discuss some high
corporation organizations Energy
Corporation of China Central Asia policy
security is the main issue of China's
interest policy as well as SEO although
the economic cooperation especially the
energy cooperation among SEO members a
brewin any cooperation among SEO members
is not equal to energy cooperation of
SEO because many clients between China
and central agencies and and the Russia
is the viola true we not the not the
multilateral way and it's not under the
framework of Shanghai Cooperation
Organization thank you all welcome
comments and questions